[Musique]
pour voir les enfants
ce soir il faut être très gentil avec
notre nounours il est triste se ferait
pas trop je me saute ou mélancolie mon
pauvre nounours descend vite chez
nicolas et pimprenelle ils vont
s'occuper toit aux ils savent me
comprendre
mon échec
hop hop
ou
bonsoir
pauvre petit
de nouveaux mélancolique
j'aimerais que vous me racontez la suite
de l'histoire du petit chat assieds toi
gros qu aucun mal à les vivre tu nous
écoutes je suis toute ouïe le fait quand
on a dit la maman chat à son tout petit
chat est à lui donne trois coups de
salon sur le pétrole à trois coups du
leader
et trois coups de langue sur son petit
bouton comme ça le tout propre la maman
s'est couché un rond dans son panier
elle c'est à 12 le petit chat il s'est
mis au chaud contre sa maman mais il ne
s'est pas endormi car ils voulaient
s'amuser bokoko à la il est sauté des
paniers sans faire de bruit et il a posé
sa petite frimousse sur le rebord de la
fenêtre
le beau ballon lune brillait dans le
ciel comme chaque soir mais ce soir-là
il brillait aussi dans l'eau de la
fontaine cette fois ci je vais bien
m'amuser et le château est sorti de la
maison sur la patte de six petites
pattes souchon allons les gratter sur le
bord de la fontaine et top avec ses
petites pattes il a essayé d'attraper le
ballon lui l'eau de la fontaine était
bien froide alors il a souffle à toutes
ses forces
attendu je souffle aussi
te fatigue pas neuf le ballon lui naples
hisser son nez il a fait un peu la
grimace mais elle reste au milieu de
l'eau au soho le chaton a pris un bâton
et ça il a tapé sur ballon lui est le
talon le nuage je t'aide lorient
alors le petit chat sauter au milieu du
masa pour attraper le ballon avec lequel
il voulait tellement joué
il est tombé dans l'eau
il a manqué s'est noyé le petit migou et
il a pleuré si fort qu'il a réveillé
tous les chats du quartier
le pauvre petit fils à maman est venue
chercher la ramener à la maison tous
mouillés points elle lui a donné trois
coups de salengro sur l'ennemi trois
coups de langue les oreilles trois coups
de la sur son petit manteau bonne fée
chez
après il a sagement fait de nautisme et
moi je connais deux enfants qui vont
faire comme le petit chat
[Musique]
bonne nuit le petit
oui
j'étais à la lueur avec ma p'tite pasto
pop
lounge à ou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'eau lourde
la parole mais tu chantes oui patron je
le suis plus triste mais de petits amis
m'ont raconté la suite de l'histoire du
petit chat j'aime tellement les
histoires et vous ne m'en raconter jab
je te raconterai c'est promis merci
patron allons en route de nuit les
enfants faute de boer
[Musique]